thank you
[Music]
everybody welcome back to another
awesome episode of the careful boys
featuring we got Mr Jesus in the
building
all right we got a little hot seat going
on today I love you know before we get
into the Odyssey in town we're gonna
start off a little cool and we're gonna
wrap our temperature up and the
replacement for Bart we got Nick the ear
ice cold guy here I like on the ear kind
of it's kind of a lot of pressure being
Bart right now because I feel like
nobody could deliver the question like
Bart then just be bored do it try your
best yes by the way I feel like
conquering a [ __ ] town or a country
with this seat dude feeling super white
right now dude sorry anyway like a real
ruler yeah dude
um what are your
porn Search keywords that's your cold
questions
that makes too much sense bro I I I'll
do it for you I'll do it for you all
right all right here you go all right I
try to do Bart style I just came up as I
say all right let me see here we go what
is your most favorite disposable one-use
plastic
what the hell are you talking about
you're talking witchcraft
what what type of foliage
is your ultimate favorite for shade
that's good that's that's good that's
good I feel different beef jerky right
after I love it
I was like what the [ __ ] is this I feel
disrespected with all those big words
and I feel like attacking somebody dude
what are you talking about foliage what
foliage foliage no it's just foliage is
it foliage hold on let me go I went to a
public school all right and I I didn't
graduate high school so tell me what the
hell you're talking about what type of
shade is your favorite shade what type
of shade is my favorite shade when you
wanna you know get out of the Sun what
kind of shade do you use palm trees you
like um you know you like earn so
confused this is a difficulty right
here's a weird this is a different type
of hot seat this is like a like uh it's
like brain teaser let's get back to a
more comfortable place what's this
I don't
like it's getting hot for sure all right
let's go Caliente a secret that I didn't
tell anybody I [ __ ] this girl and then
I [ __ ] her friend at the same night
like I went to her apartment and we did
her thing and we and she passed out and
then I left and she was like her friend
was like in the living room I guess
hearing us and then I was just like yeah
and she just started talking I was what
are you watching this and that he's like
oh and then she's like Sarah here and I
was like yeah and then I'm like oh she's
trying to [ __ ] so then I smashed her too
and she got hurting by listening to the
moans I think so I think she got hot and
ready and I just [ __ ] ended up
smashing her enter and I'm like what the
[ __ ] just happened but the thing is like
that was like my girlfriend at the time
so I [ __ ] her friend and I had to play
it off like I you know yeah yeah so did
the second time feel like so I never
told her about that so she just found
out these brain's about to explode the
only [ __ ] works
okay he looked like he never was it's
never happened to me nah this guy's he's
our local sex
did the second one feel like did the
second one feel like I can't come
anymore but I can't say no the second oh
you know what I mean yeah
I'm the victim here like what do you
want from me I can't [ __ ] I can't do
this you got used but I can't say no to
this because it's like wow yeah yeah
dude because you're a gentleman right
you know you can't just [ __ ] it was that
the only time or did you did you guys
smash again later
so it was definitely like one little
smash Fest that was going on between
them and [ __ ] so how long did this last
for this lasted for like a half a year
oh [ __ ] that's what's going on wow good
for you man what boy what's the secret
the secret is you know just [ __ ]
freaking more cocktail be Latino dude I
think he's just in me you know the mid
generation of my grandpa just you know
having multiple families not telling
anyone hey Ryan
but it's like my version but toned down
a little bit you know what I mean the
next level right you don't actually have
the babies right yeah you'll get tied
down I'm not an animal
just for your grandpa is just like well
we gotta get married now no when I was
young you know when I was young I was
you know wow boy how old were you at
that time oh I was like probably 21 20.
are you in a relationship now yes I am
and do you I don't think you know what I
don't think she knows about these
stories he's gonna be like allegedly
allegedly and does she have a best
friend oh no her friends trust me I
would not not my type not that would
happen God damn the hot scene
this is the best first five minutes
let's see yeah you're getting more out
of me than my therapist what do you
think would happen if your girlfriend
right now saw this video saw that story
how would she react first thing she
would not look at anything because she
knows she's like I don't want to know
you're gross I don't wanna know you
wouldn't even like anything has to do
with people sending her videos I don't
want another [ __ ] whatever wow she
thinks she thinks I'm gross so oh that
must have worked out well in the
beginning yeah you know you can play the
best version of yourself and then she
found out like oh he's a [ __ ] he's an
[ __ ] did she know you're a stand-up
comedian yeah yeah we met we met Because
She interviewed me she's like in the
entertainment business and stuff like
she's a booking agent or whatever no I
don't know she's like uh she uh she's
like a sports like host oh wow that's
cool for like boxing and baseball and
stuff so yeah and how many days did you
go on her before you guys do you [ __ ]
you guys are just we found a hole yeah
these games
we found a soft spot I'm telling you
dude my therapist can't even get this
out of me dude I'm just like yeah
where the first day what how many dates
until you guys full pushed whoa
wrong time
it is the softest sex I've ever heard
those are proper I took a it took a
while you know just you know yeah slow
time yeah we just this one was different
because I feel like we just connected
very well like we were on the phone for
like hours I'm like I'm a phone guy oh
[ __ ] I'm uh what are you wearing nah
I'ma said you sent me a text and I'm
like yo I call you I don't text I'll
call you and then girls don't like wait
what's going on but I know how to talk I
can you can talk on the conversation I
have stories I can you know I'm not
calling feels so personal these days
that's the thing that's how you [ __ ]
you know he doesn't watch any of this
stuff for sure no she doesn't watch this
you buy ring it
guys
get in there I'll never tell
oh my God guys he's literally blushy
right now yeah no you thinking about it
though I mean yeah yeah
no no no no many years dude have you
been together like I think I like I
think probably like three years three
years three years when when did when did
it hit you like oh my God I think this
is the one this is different this is
different was like even when
when I was annoyed I still loved her and
I was like oh you know what it's still
over though like I mean I wouldn't argue
with her I would you didn't feel like
get out of here like dude I'm out like
what's
up so I would go back and we'll talk it
out I never talked it out whoa that's a
big that's a good sign yeah that's a big
sign changing because I before I used to
be very just like I don't give a [ __ ]
whatever but more I'm just like all
right you're I'm starting to say sorry
like all right I'm sorry that's all you
know
yeah the sorry start coming no she's
like you know she's grown so she's like
tells me my [ __ ] she calls me out she's
very strong woman so I'm like oh [ __ ] I
never had is she older than you yeah she
is older so that's why that maturity I
think the maturity yeah
maturity did you guys like ever do like
anal yeah dude
freaking future wife you're talking
about
no yeah we're talking about yeah dude I
mean those steps you know dude I'm left
you know you're doing all kinds of [ __ ]
you know come on man really yeah so has
she pegged you she hasn't no you see
human that kind of anal that I don't
know depending what's up it just says
it's so sweet I don't butt play yet I
don't butt play the only you know I
don't can't go down there yeah yeah I
haven't really like played
[Laughter]
though one of my more mature guys Steve
he would probably ask something like um
would you rather [ __ ] your mom or your
dad
well I mean well
I mean well it's not JK unless you ask
Mom it's not it's my dad's a jerk no
explain would you guys actually we all
answered yeah you have to answer it when
you're here or [ __ ] my mom or my dad and
why and why and how yeah what's Julius
Julia Julia's [ __ ] in dude she's been
JK you guys don't even know I know I
feel like I'm just getting a note
um two moms getting [ __ ]
come on dude just getting [ __ ]
smashed I mean I'm not gonna [ __ ] my dad
get out of here dude I'm not gonna lie
learn my cheese though bro what do you
want me to do what do you want for me
did you answer it did you get are you
just [ __ ] with me
who's weak now we both said that we both
said that Power Trip all the guys with
Daddy yes you said that yeah yeah for
sure I have Daddy issue me too happy
issues Pappy issues that's a good one
man he's going through these questions
really good he's no no no diverting I
like that yeah we should just only ask
him cold questions
what are you talking about that's the
point of a cold question that's when you
sit next to the [ __ ] Band Geeks at
the [ __ ] lunch because there's no
more seats you're like what are you guys
[ __ ] talking about
are you guys talking about you're so
left out you know oh dude not just
something similar to what he was asking
what about your uh your porn search
titles what is a keyword that you happen
to be or a keyword that you're having to
look into I'll tell you right now dude
and it's weird I don't know what's going
on Arabic anything Arabic
and like
um
maybe I think that's why Mia Khalifa got
so popular no no but it's like Arabic
and then uh home like footage like like
phone not like proper [ __ ] setup I
like CCTV like something that was like
I'm not supposed to be seeing this is
like a for them video it's more intimate
yeah it's not well produced yeah for
some reason it just makes you more
forbidden so amateur and that's weird
but that's just like yeah but the way
you said forbid it sounds like the way
it's supposed to be said for reading for
me
[Laughter]
before even press play they tell you
like this is repeating enjoy
I'm just right there dude I'm just like
everything with the lotion
look everybody out nobody in the house
this is for beating it's like the Dos
Equis guys it comes out of nowhere they
just were beating you know that right
so why'd you get in the stand up why did
I just dude I was born into stantom I
just like was always I didn't know how
to not be funny I was always trying to
like connect this I hated like awkward
moments I just crash and burn yeah yeah
a bunch of times yeah stand up was like
my biggest fear was to bomb but then I
kept bombing and I realized like this
ain't [ __ ] yeah it's good this is what I
do like I thought it was gonna be worse
you know what I mean but bombing is like
whatever and I'm like I'm [ __ ] just
gonna you know keep going what made you
want to move out to LA and pursue it
because this is the only way I can like
work in my small town in Tucson there
was only like one Comedy Club I'll go
there once a week so then I was like if
I want to be great I got to be around
the greats I gotta learn because I was
following guys that have been doing it
all drunk and been doing it for like 10
years barely had five minutes and I was
like riding like crazy so yeah so do
Comics have like groupies
we're not like rock stars we're talking
about
dicks and girls aren't really like I
want to [ __ ] that guy who talked about
his uncircumcised dick I don't know
that's not true I have some crushes on
comedians really absolutely
oh really that guy was a good writer I
mean he still is but yeah there was um
Dane Cook was like all of his audience
was women yeah I mean it was not like a
Comics comic but but he isn't I mean I
can't stand up I'll tell you what with
me I I think it should maybe it's just
me my [ __ ] is like I don't get girls
like I see Comics that get girls I never
really got girl I do I did get girls
yeah you did but it wasn't like the
[ __ ] [ __ ] fest like Dane Cook and
this and that like I would just get like
cougars and like regular girls girls
that just been through [ __ ] you're just
like [ __ ] God damn girl like all this
like you know married chicks I'm like
[ __ ] so much like [ __ ] you don't want to
get chased out by their husband and [ __ ]
right yeah but you're like still there
because you're like thanks it's like
forbidden sex
enjoy
you know how many times I've been with
the [ __ ] like I can't believe oh my
God and I'm just like [ __ ] you know
right here you're married forbidden yeah
so I don't really get groupies like that
uh and then now and especially when I
was younger I was very like focused like
I just came here to work I'm trying to
[ __ ] blow up like JK news over here
with the [ __ ] vanishes get millions
of views
wearing a wig what the [ __ ]
yeah but who's a comic you think uh
deserves more praise in today's time and
then who's a comment that you think is
getting too much credit
uh a guy who I think is gonna like blow
up and I know it already is uh uh Jason
Cheney for real bro dude everybody loves
him he doesn't even know he's nice and
he's like super cool Jason Cheney's
gonna blow up and I tell every time we
talk I'm always like well you're gonna
blow up I already know I'm gonna [ __ ]
open up for you he's like oh dude don't
don't you know how he is and then it
turns to [ __ ] grab a [ __ ] it's weird
really you think so showing you his
penis oh you're so nice you're gonna
blow up I know and like shut the [ __ ] up
dude but anyways that guy uh should be
obviously the biggest and then the guy
that I'm just like
I don't know dude I don't like to start
problems
I'm not saying though he may not be your
gym yeah the guy who I'm just kind of
like um and people are just like going
crazy over
[ __ ]
uh maybe maybe it could be like rhymes
with
ah no I can't say it no nevermind no I'm
trying I got I got a question before
before you ruin your career how do you
uh uh feel about there's just so many
people coming into stand-up comedy you
know what I hate and I'm glad you're
saying it you know what I [ __ ] there's
so many
Roadies that be following these [ __ ]
whack-ass Comics these guys are putting
okay right now what's happening in the
comedy world there's a lot of comedians
that are blowing up quack Quick Quack
Quack Quack Quack quick
because of [ __ ] Instagram video clips
yeah they just post a little clip one
thing that worked for that little second
and they just think like oh these guys
know what they're doing and they go and
they see them and they pay to go watch
them and they're clearly brand new and
they're just starting they don't have
[ __ ] an hour they don't know how to
hang they don't know how to react if you
[ __ ] put them in this hot seat they
don't know how to [ __ ] you know be on
point yeah dude so and that's what are
frustrating right now because I put in
all these years and these guys are
popping yeah and selling tickets and I'm
like God these are spoken like a true
comedian yeah you know what I mean
you're just one of those like you gotta
earn this this [ __ ] isn't given to you
you gotta just do viral social media
clips and I am starting to do it because
at first it was a whole like [ __ ] I'm
trying to perfect this craft yeah and
then but it's like [ __ ] that that I'm
falling behind becoming the old guy in
the room with the [ __ ] newspaper and
the wall trying to figure out this
murder and I'm just like I need to
[ __ ] go out there and do it I need to
go out there but you you have an HBO
[ __ ] specialist That's what I'm
saying instead of giving away material I
saved it for the HBO special like you're
supposed to but then now I'm seeing like
social media is a new beast and I'm like
oh you know what I gotta just for the
people who haven't seen that the HBO is
special just take little clips from that
well that's what I'm starting to do yeah
I'm starting to just take it and stuff
I'm old school [ __ ] mentality
business where it's just like I'm trying
to do it the right way with managers and
ages and I'm like oh [ __ ] that I gotta
just be like play the game a little bit
Yeah play the little young game and [ __ ]
not clear not saying you got any but
what what would you maybe consider as
one of your biggest regrets my biggest
regrets with uh not starting uh YouTube
like these guys were doing that was my
biggest regret because I saw you guys I
saw a couple other people like on
YouTube and I remember thinking like nah
that's not that's not I really didn't
think it was gonna go anywhere I thought
a lot of people didn't think what I'm
doing is right this is going gonna go
somewhere standard was gonna eventually
and it's like I was wrong it [ __ ] was
wrong a lot of people thought that
though because David in our Circle I was
like you gotta blow up your channel you
got known for your channel and like
stand up like yeah there's a lot of
pride and respect in that art and that
craft but what you got to do is think
about your career and how you're gonna
pay for your life right the stand-up
traditional grind it's an artist's grind
it's totally different and it's
respectable but if you want to pay your
bills this is the easier way to do it
but like I think that conversation is
hard for people who are purists like I
think for all art you gotta go through
that Crossroad and be like all right
this is how I wanna do things like and
be a master at it but then am I gonna be
happy doing this [ __ ] and I and I think
everybody feels that for me there was no
opportunity elsewhere
for what I wanted to do right because I
was like I was just like I'm gonna do it
here yeah because like I wanted to do a
a comedy channel but experiment with it
and then there's nothing on TV for that
for Vietnamese Funk bands got yeah right
but what you do but what you did they
created the market but they did and I
think what you did we would understand
like what you have is the dream like you
guys right here it's like you guys
[ __ ] you are your bosses and I like
that you have a [ __ ] guy going up to
you telling you what to say it's got a
oh it's it's got its own set of problems
but it also it's [ __ ] cool that you
guys are young and you guys are out here
yeah I mean when I was working in with
3K I would complain to Joe a lot all the
time really yeah well you yeah you look
like the complainer and then Joe would
just get all frustrated and he's like
God damn it
I mean it's a give and take right like
so like it's a feeling a lot of PTSD
over here yeah what's going on here
sometimes let's get some cold questions
when you when you like when you have a
when you can just focus on your craft
right yeah you could really Excel and do
just that but then in in for me I had to
choose do I want to be like a comedic
actor only or do I want to build a
company and then so like when you build
it you can't always necessarily like
ride on every opportunity that comes to
you like sometimes you get an
opportunity but you like I got a company
too can I I can't do both right so it's
like you toss one and you you gotta you
know be with the group okay so there's
just other sacrifice yeah but dude
that's nothing compared to the [ __ ]
guys who have to wake up imagine when
you were waking up and going to that job
that you [ __ ] hated the people you
were just annoyed with that you have to
be cool with that that sucked especially
when you had this talent that you're
like I want to do something and there's
do you know how many people right now
are at that job who wanted to do this
the idea was here but the difference
between them and you was the fact that
you actually took a chance that's the
only difference between you and the guy
right now it's [ __ ] Starbucks who
wants to [ __ ] do it because that same
guy at Starbucks is like watching our
YouTube videos and it's like would you
rather [ __ ] your mom or your dad yeah
yeah all right that's what I want to do
that could be me he's going with the
conflict too like well Mom you know she
has to put it out [ __ ] mom but to Dad
I do want that Power Trip
pickle
but you know in the end of the day you
know I just I'm glad to be doing what I
love and getting paid for so that's
that's pretty cool it took a while you
have your own company or not everyone
here took the risk to kind of go toward
whatever they wanted to so I mean being
from these cameras is a risky thing to
do to be like all right I'm gonna
[ __ ] get myself out there and see
what people think and this is a scary
thing to do it takes strong people yeah
for it oh no it takes a strong you know
set of person to do what we do it's like
this is not easy yeah yeah so imagine
being told [ __ ] you every day of your
lives multiple times a day yeah you got
to start reading those comments man yeah
Mom yeah dude
and I think a part of it has to do with
the way I grew up that I'm like if
people are like trying to hurt me with
comments and hecklers and I'm like you
can't hurt bro there's a reason why I'm
up here my life is already to [ __ ] like
you're not gonna hurt me dude there's
nothing you can say yeah it's gonna hurt
me dude
yeah no but then she's gonna hear about
the merry part and she'd be like you
want to marry oh God you guys are
starting up a conversation um so I saw
something
[Laughter]
but it's how you feel dude
at least give me a hint so I could be
dressed for it oh my gosh you sent
pictures and stuff already so I'm like I
already know relax relax I'm a size this
in my room yeah I know yeah though yeah
yeah get those sizes my boy the size and
all that stuff and I'm just like [ __ ]
dude all of her best friends like you
wouldn't [ __ ] me yeah
[Music]
all her friends got like I need someone
affect me
whatever I don't want to [ __ ] him anyway
they [ __ ] Corner me in a party hey I
just want to know like like what the
[ __ ]
I know like elaboration but like all of
them as a collective imagine that's not
that's high he saw that JK video it's a
highly I think of myself anyways
foreign